i'll now show you how to create a simple
calculator app let's begin creating a
calculator app in android studio once
the android studio is launched you can
see this window which is divided into
two parts
the left part displays all the recent
projects on the right side you can see
an option which states start a new
android studio project click on it a new
window will appear here you can give
your application name by default it is
my application here there is also a
company domain field which is connected
to your package name i'll change the
project name to calculator and then
click on next it will lead us to another
window where you will have to select
minimum sdk version by default it is an
api level 15 that is ice cream sandwich
which is good to go proceed by clicking
next here you have to choose activity
from another window choose blank
activity and click next now you have to
give layout and java class name by
default the java class name is main
activity and xml will be activity under
scoremain.xml
keep it as it is and then click finish
it will take few minutes to set the
gradle to build as per the project api
level finally your project setup is
complete now please pay attention as
i'll create the ui design for the
calculator in this design i'll create
buttons from zero to nine and one clear
button basic operations like plus minus
multiplication subtraction division and
one text view to display the result to
create the design for calculator first i
will go to activity underscore main dot
xml which is under res package and
layout and delete the floating button
design
i will then go to mainactivity.java
and delete the corresponding code for
floating button select layout under res
package and double click on content
underscore main.xml file which will
appear on editor i will make this linear
layout orientation vertical
then i will create five relative layouts
with the same height using layout weight
is equal to one inside the top relative
layout i will declare a text view to
display the result it will contain width
as fill parent and height as match
parent
i will set the id as result underscore
id
i will go to the next relative layout
and inside it i will declare a linear
layout i'll set bit as fill parent and
height as match parent set orientation
as horizontal gravity as center and give
some space from top so we'll say padding
top 10 dp inside the linear layout i'll
create a button and set layout width to
0dp and set layout height to match
parent layout weight as 1 and text size
to 30sp and text as 7 to display on
button
similarly i'll create another three
buttons and for rest of the relative
layout after completing you can see the
design on the right side panel of your
xml design preview
after completing the design i'll go to
mainactivity.java
which is under the java package double
click on it the editor appears now i
will declare globally a string name str
which will display the result now i will
declare a character name op which will
hold all the operation now two more
variables as float which are num and num
temp which will hold the number for
temporary one text view will be declared
to hold the same results name show
result
finally i'll declare all buttons which
will be used like 0 to 9 and also all
the operation
now inside oncreate operation i'll
declare all buttons like this
i will use on click operation for each
button from 0 to 9 button i'll use
insert function which i will create in
the later part of this tutorial
for operation button on click i will
create perform function
in clear button i'll create a function
name reset
outside of oncreate method i'll create
all the user defined function i
mentioned
start with reset it will be private
method in this every function i'll set
all the variable what i did at first
next i'll create insert function in
which i will pass a parameter inside
this function i'll store the value in
str then i will convert to integer and
store it in num and will set the result
to show result text view
next i'll create perform function inside
that i'll make string as empty and will
store the value of num into num temp
finally i'll create calculate function
to perform all the operation using if
else statement this completes the app
development
now run an emulator launch the
calculator and you can use it
you